Now, in this section of working with Cine Camera Actors, we're going to take a brief
look at the other optional camera components that you might use frequently in Unreal Engine.
When working with Cine Camera Actors, these three camera components can enhance your ability
to work with Unreal Engine.
The first being a Scene Capture Component 2D.
Now, this component captures a simple snapshot of the scene from a camera and feeds it directly
into a render target texture.
Working with the release of Unreal Engine 5.3, Unreal Engine introduced a new component
called the Cine Capture Component 2D.
This is a plugin that is in beta, and it extends the capabilities of the Capture Component
that respects the Cine Camera settings, allowing you to have color profiles such as OCIO, correct
depth of field, lens distortion, and a one-to-one view of the Cine Camera captured and then
applied to the render target texture.
Just like the Scene Capture Component 2D, but better.
The third component that you are likely to work with is the Vcam Actor.
This virtual camera component is used to transmit camera motion and control settings remotely
through the Live Link plugin and companion app found on the Apple Store.
Alright, that's it for this camera component section of working with Cine Camera Actors.
In our next section, I'm going to walk you through a step-by-step guide that I've created
for you to follow along and build a control rig for use with a Cine Camera Actor for
more realistic camera animation.